Uh, we didn't hit innovation in other
careers. Worries. No. No. Here's one. Oh,
we never even gotten the cars flying
cars. Why? They'll never be foreign cars.
Yeah, man, man, I started
with this please. Okay.
Since we're two hours and 40 minutes
in, does that allowed? Oh my gosh. Yeah,
we're flying. People don't have
full three hours to do they, oh,
we did it all the time. Really?
Yeah. Oh, are you sure? 100% yeah.
This is not you. Sure. Yeah.
Average podcasts right now.
Like average. Really? Yeah.
I'm honored to bleach your average,
the ones we've done.
We've all been like close to three
hours. Okay, here you go. Here you go.
Is that a ding? I don't dare. I was
rude. Okay, so let me, I flipped it.
I turned that goddamn switch on.
Okay,
so let's go back to flying cars.
Let's go back to why anyone would want
a flying car in the first place because
they're an asshole. Okay, go here. It
is stuck in traffic. So here at Edison,
everybody just watch, let's say
there's only one road. Okay. Okay.
There was the width of your car and
you're driving on this road and the cars
behind you the fastest you could go on
that road is the speed of the slowest car
on the road. Right? Makes Sense.
Yes. This is travel in one dimension.
That sucks. What you really want
is travel in two dimensions,
so you take the road and widen it.
Let's make two lanes,
two lanes in one direction.
We can have two of the other way as well.
This doesn't matter.
Here you have two lights,
so now I can go around
you your slow ass car.
Okay,
but and that's fine.
This was a great improvement
on one dimensional travel.
Now it's two dimensions.
Okay.
I can shift left or right as well as
move forward or backwards to move and the
more lanes you have, the more
two dimensional that is. Okay.
The four oh five here in Los Angeles.
What does it six lanes each.
It's 12 fricking lanes.
Okay.
You are fully exploiting the
two dimensionality of travel,
but you still have so many
cars that you say to yourself,
I want to bypass this traffic.
If you went from one dimension
to two dimensions, bypassing
is just another lane,
but now all 12 lanes are plugged and you
want to bypass it. So you're thinking,
I need to travel in another dimension.
I want to travel in the third dimension.
If I do that,
I can bypass all these cars.
I want a flying car. Yeah.
Okay. Well the point is we
already have flying cars.
They called helicopters. Well, the
helicopters originally invented for that.
They called helicopters.
They're noisy.
They have to create a downward thrust
of air equal to its own weight.
If you're going to have a
flying car, that's what it's
going to have to do. Right?
They're noisy.
They're,
they completely disrupt the
terrain wherever they fly.
So the issue is not that
you want a flying car,
you want to travel in that third
dimension. Mm. We already do that.
How do we do that? The call
tunnels, they called bridges.
When you have a huge intersection,
you don't move people through one another.
You build the,
you build one road over the other,
you build one road under the other.
You are exploiting three dimensions.
So that traffic can go in perpendicular
directions simultaneously.
That's what the flying
cars would have given you.
But we do that at intersections because
it would be impossible to move 12 lanes
of traffic through an intersection
that crossed another freeway.
New York City has done this.
We do this.
The New York, you're in the streets,
there's too many cars you can't move.
Let's move in the third dimension.
Let's build a subway.
This sounds like a guy who's
trying to sell me something,
telling you better than a flying car.
I'll just like listen man,
that flying cars bullshit. You
could buy a flying car. The new,
I want you to appreciate moving in.
The third dimension to New
York City subway system
moves a billion people a year
and they all go in the third dimension
beneath the ground through tunnels,
tunnels that are layered on
top of one another. Well,
the New York City subway
system is amazing.
How doubt about you couldn't move
that many people. It's great,
but it's not as good as a flying car.
It's not as cool as a flying car,
but it's as effective as a flying car.
The flying car,
personal flying car has to have to get
in line, he'd have to get on the subway.
You don't have to have a token and
you'd have to go through the turnstile.
You have to deal with.
Some guy was rubbing his body up
against yours flying cars. So Shit,
you just fly around.
I'm just saying it's like a boat tunnels.
But for the air and
bridges or flying cars,
the beautiful thing about a boat is
you just go wherever you want to go.
Now here's the thing,
it's kind of,
you don't have to call air
traffic control turning left.
I would take it to another dimension.
Not someone will have to know where the
hell you're flying cars going just the
same way.
Traffic rules then matter in the street.
You know it is with boats and you don't,
what happens if a car fails?
False. It's just on the, on the
ground. It just stops. Right?
Flying car fails. You're
dead. Right. Okay. So, uh,
I want to add another dimension to this
conversation. Oh, he redlined mosquitoes.
Tunnels. Okay. Ready? Exactly. Exactly.
So Watch, here's a desk in front of me.
Okay. I, it's a physical desk and I
have a lot of sheets of paper and I,
and so I lay them side by side. I tile
the desk with all my sheets of paper.
Then there's no desk surface left.
I ran out of two dimensional space.
If I want to store more pages on my desk,
what do I do?
I get one of those organizers.
I've just introduced a third dimension.
So now I could have pages in another
dimension sitting above the page that was
previously occupying another place
that I couldn't have put another sheet.
That's three dimensions. Yes. Okay.
If we were two dimensional people,
we would wonder what happened to that
sheet of paper cause we have no access to
that third dimension. You would, it would
just left our universe at this point.
I'd be trying to back out of the
showroom and I'd say thank you,
but I'm going to go to the
flying car place. So now watch.
But look at how much you've increased
your storage by introducing another
dimension.
Now imagine a fourth spacial dimension.
We don't have access to that,
but we're now filling all three dimensions
and afforded mentioned creature will
say,
well just put it up in this direction.
What would be the fourth
dimension in that regard?
You can't imagine it because our brain
evolved in three dimensions. We haven't,
we can describe it mathematically.
Maybe a hole in Pasadena. Racism.
So our storage needs would
be con you can open a door,
put it through this portal to the fourth
dimension and closed the door and look
on the other side of the door
and nothing would be there. Yeah,
just the way on the surface of the desk.
If you live in the surface and
that's someone opens a door,
they put the paper through the door,
close the door,
and you look around and you say,
where did it go? I have no idea.
Cause you can't even see. You can't
even imagine that third dimension.
We cannot imagine a fourth dimension.
But if the world one day gets so crowded
that even three dimensional space has
traffic, access to a fourth
dimension would greatly help that.
That's all I'm saying.
Yeah. Good luck with that.
Getting people to step through ice tea.
What is this Jamie?
Some flying thing that just came out last.
Oh, look at this thing. Wait, that's CG.
That part seems CGI, but it's actually
flying over grass that's moving it.
Look at this thing. What is it? Solar
powered? I don't know. The trailer,
like showing it, describing it makes it
have sound. Does it make sound? What?
It looks like? It looks like
a human sized. A drone. Yes.
That's exactly what it looks like.
Okay. What about something like this?
What about something like this
with really powerful magnets?
All side of the outer edge.
So it repels against other drones
to want a maglev flying cars.
So if you get so close. Oh, I see.
It'd be like forcefield Laminar
each other. Oh, so it'd be like,
it'd be like a bumper cars. Yes, but
with, with cushions? Yes. Yeah. Yeah.
Some sort of electromagnetic
force field that you know,
everyone agrees that you don't have
ones that are attracted to each other,
but are opposed,
by the way,
see how big that human north
human sized drones drone is.
Have you ever heard how loud a
drone? It fucking loud. You can't,
you can't even have a conversation. Yeah,
I've got an asshole in my neighborhood.
Flies on around you. That's
what shotguns are for. Yeah.
I wish I had never fired a gun in my
life for the first time I ever used one.
It's to shoot the drone that's going
to be looking through my window at my
apartment. Oh yeah. This is
fucking asshole in my neighborhood.
He flies all over people's
yards and I can't uncork.
They already think I'm crazy. No Way. I,
and if I shoot it with a bow and Arrow,
I'm not sure I'll hit it. By the way,
did that video have a sound accompanying
with it has some, some a little bit.
There's music and some
description of it was music,
but it's not the actual sound of those
propellers they have on their webpage
here that it's quieter than
a car on a freeway. What?
It's quite an electric
car nor at 150 feet away.
Measured at 150 feet. That's incredible.
Oh cause it's about the same as,
as as a car. Well, it says
motorcycles don't count.
So they're counting that as an electric
car though. Oh, they are? Yeah. Yeah.
Gasoline cars. But cars today
are not in top. Wait, wait,
just to be energy consumption.
I don't know if they're using
the same icon to represent. See,
they're using the same show.
It's an electric electric car.
So it's the sound of an electric car.
No, no. There's no engine. But no,
don't get deceived there because
that's energy consumption.
The energy consumption uses the
same icon for electric cars.
It does for gasoline car and
then down. No. See it says noise.
It shows highway, just car. It doesn't
tell you which of those DBA. Right?
There's no way.
76 DBA says sound because electric
cars far quieter than a regular car.
You, all you hear is the
drone of the tire. So,
but what happens is above a certain speed,
the,
the aerodynamic noise is greater than the,
so it'll landing airplanes. Here's,
here's what you do. You live in la,
go to the in and out near lax,
which is right near a landing strip.
Okay. Yeah. And listen to the
sound of the planes as they come,
as they come in for a landing. Most
of that sound is air foil, noise,
not engine noise. Uh, yeah.
Which is why you can pretty much
still maintain a conversation.
You're old enough.
We remember a plane would fly overhead
in a city and you'd have to halt your
conversation until it
finished. Why? What happened?
Engine's got quieter and quieter,
which enabled people to build real estate
closer and closer to airports and not
have not have a sound problem. It's poor.
Fuck. But it didn't happen overnight.
It was slow and steady. No kidding.
Yeah. I never, I forgot her foil noise.
I forgot that you had to stop
talking when I remember it. In fact,
Shea Stadium in New York City
near near Laguardia Airport,
the announcers had to stop. Anytime
I plane flew overhead, they couldn't,
couldn't announce the game.
That's crazy.
And when the mets won
the world series in 1969,
mayor Lindsay redirected the airport
traffic to not fly over the world series
games. Wow. I thought that was a bad
ass move of him. Of his mayor, Lindsay.
1960. Yeah. I completely forgot
how loud planes you do submit.
Correct. And now they're, now
they're, it's a sound that's in the,
in the noise of the street.
You don't even stop and notice it.
You didn't even pay attention. All
you barely hear, you barely hear it.
And so next time you're at a
runway and when it's landing,
it's much noisier taking off cause
it's got a gain altitude. Right?
But coming down, it's, most
of that sound is glider noise.
And evidence of this is, uh, is uh,
the noise of air going over the air
foil of the, the fuselage. If you do,
you know, the moment they
deploy the, the landing gear,
next time you're in an airplane,
when they say we are clear for landing,
just listen,
listen to the ambient sound of the plane.
Then listen to the sound.
After they deploy their landing,
it's for three times as loud.
It ramps up hard part because of the
sound of the air going around something
that's not aerodynamic. Uh,
the fricking wheels. Oh yes.
Yeah, yeah. I just never,
for whatever reason,
I never remembered that airplanes used
to be louder. I think about all the time.
So why can't I have a flying
car? It's still, you want
the drone flying car? Yeah.
Yeah. So you need, if
you wouldn't want it,
that would look ugly if two of
those collide and in the sky.
But what about my magnet theory?
But now,
now it's got to have more power to
lift the way to the magnet solar pro.
Plus he gets some testosterone infuse
guy who doesn't want to let you ahead of
them to bump. You break the propeller
and then you both fall out of the sky.
Sky Rage, sky rage. Ah, it's a
lot of Dirage. We know it'll do,
it'll call the herd of testosterone
driven men. Okay. But what if they do it,
but the only way they work is through
like the same sort of Tesla system that
allows them to have,
you know what cars,
I don't know if you have automated cars,
you don't need flying cars. Yeah you do.
Because first it'll be too many of them.
There'll be fewer cars on the road, but
okay.
How do you figure that? Oh my gosh.
Automated cars. Any fewer cars?
Yes. How so? How so? How so? Because,
because what your second
greatest asset your car,
most people second greatest asset
spends 90% of his time doing nothing.
You drive to work in his parked you
come home and it's parked right.
90% of his time doing nothing. Okay.
I come to work 10 minutes after you,
I half hour after you and hour
after you I'm using your car.
You ain't using my car. I'm telling
you right now. You're not using my car.
No one's using it anyways cause I forgot.
This is la.
Did you go to New York habit for people
steal your car is a utility rather than
uh, uh, something to try to get chicks
with on the street corner. Oh stop.
He will try to get chicks in New York too.
Don't put the cars.
There's a lot of people that do. Nobody
has cars. But if you do, you're a baller.
You got one of them spots.
It cost you 1000 bucks a month baby.
I've seen some fancy cars and I've been
in New York, so there's some fancy guns,
but that's not, it's not it.
It's not 100% it's not 100% yeah,
but that's just that one stupid spot
where everybody could still own the car,
but you'll be delegate relegated to a
lane where you won't be able to drive as
fast as the automated car.
Consider that if you were in a self
driving car and it wants to change lanes,
it communicates that to other self driving
cars near it and they've self driving
cars tell you to fuck off because
you have the program. But like that,
I have a rude assumption that Joe Rogan
upload some rude Russian Bot called.
It's not letting anybody in
the Joe Rogan upload that.
I feel like it wouldn't change anything
if there's automated cars in Los Angeles.
I really do. I don't think, I don't
think there'd be any less traffic.
I just think you're going to make a lane
that'll take automated cars and it will
go 120 miles an hour and watching
everybody with their wasted horsepower in
their, in their, in their can
trapped, stuck in traffic.